well let's get some more reaction now to
the harry and megan interview the duke
and duchess of sussex
made a series of serious claims with
harry saying that prince charles
had at one point stopped taking his
calls and alleged that he'd been
trapped in the royal system the couple
also discussed racism with harry saying
it hurt
that his family did not speak out
against articles with colonial
undertones written about his wife well
joining me now is dean stott who is a
friend of prince harry
great to talk to you dean why do you
think prince harry wanted to do this
interview
um i think obviously up until now
there's been a lot of hearsay you know
what we would be
reading in the media it's an opportunity
for them to
give you know dispel any sort of hearsay
with fact you know the real reasons why
they decided to step back or you know
had to step back
and also you know the 12 month
transition period is
is now over and it was then obviously
almost having a baseline
no this is where we are now this is our
decision up until now and why we've made
those decisions and this is what we're
doing moving forward
what did you think of the interview
itself did did you did you see your
friend there was harry very much being
himself
yeah he was you know if it was a
powerful it was honest uh
sometimes is uncomfortable but obviously
you know like the james cord interview
is
humanized the couple you know the james
called interview i thought was great
because that was the harry that i knew
you know very humorous
and and here he was you know he had his
heart on his sleeve
but yeah it was a difficult to watch at
times um but i
obviously understand why they've done
what they've done
had he shared any of his concerns with
you the
some of the things they raised you know
his relationship with his dad
questions over over archie's skin color
megan's mental health
there was a lot of stuff there there's
some stuff i knew already and there's
some stuff i wasn't aware of
you know it was very i said very
uncomfortable to hear something
especially you know
you talk about the race element but no
megan you know voicing her mental health
problems and reaching out for help and
there's no help there you know i
raised 900 000 pounds for the royal
foundation for one of their mental
health campaigns so i know
that they're aware of it and how
important it is and when someone from
their own household
can't get assistance you know that was
really difficult for me to hear
why do you think that is because as you
say they have done so much to raise
awareness
of of mental health issues um and and
i've done so much to speak publicly on
it
i think from this interview why you got
there's a big distinction
between the royal family and the
institution you know megan and harry
very respectful for the royal family you
know
talk very highly of the queen and other
members of the family but when it came
to the institution it seemed like
you know when harry mentioned that their
family are trapped
it sounds to me that there's no voice
there from the royal family
do you think he did the right thing
removing himself from from what he
clearly saw as a very toxic situation
and and
you know taking the ultimate step and
leaving the country all together
yeah well he talks about an interview
that there was no protection and no
security i mean later on the interview
talks about the parallels between
you know his mother and megan so you
know he saw history repeating itself
and he doesn't want to be following
another coffin so he took action and
obviously this is what they've done
i mean do you really think that that
lives were in danger because
it's not it's not the royal family who
are in charge of security and protection
is it it's a
it's the metropolitan police it's not
the royal family's call for a start
it's not their call but when you're in
line to the throne and obviously be
aware that harry has also served
in afghanistan so the threat to him is
very different from that the other
members of the family just being part of
that family there is a threat there is a
security risk and i'm a security kind of
consultant myself and then that family
you know very much
high risk at all times and so to not
have
the support or the security from the
metropolitan police you know he's now
had to fund that himself
was that and that was a real source of
concern for him was it whilst he was
still living in the uk
not so much in the uk when he was
stepping back you know at all when he
went to canada
that you know his security got taken
from him and for harry he mentions in
the interview that you know
all he wanted to do is be able to
support his family and be able to fund
that security
do you think he will ever come back to
the uk to live
to live i don't know but definitely to
come back to the to the uk
you know he's he's he's a soldier first
as a prince and he always
talks about you know his service and you
know
they didn't get stripped they they
stepped back and they still
still love the queen they still love the
commonwealth and they still want some
sort of
role within that but there will be some
and there are critics of the couple who
will say well that they
they want their cake and also you know
to eat it as well
um you know they want to be able to
decide what they speak about and they
want to be
out in public when they want to be but
they they don't want any of the negative
stuff that comes with it
i think what they they've said yes
they're always going to have your your
critics there they've always said
that they never said that they don't
want to be in the limelight you know
that what they're
choosing is difference between intrusion
and consent when it comes to media now
they have their own
media company itself actual productions
they understand that
media is a tool and a platform
especially for the archaeol foundation
they just obviously don't like this
journalistic integrity their question
do you think they were right to do the
interview is it something that you would
have recommended to them to do
i think so i think obviously there's
been so much here saying so much you
know
the media vilifying megan it was an
opportunity for her
to say how it is you know these are the
facts you know before it was all white
noise and second guessing what
was going on but now we've actually
heard it from as i say the horse's mouth
you know here we go um and do you think
you know we understand that they've said
that this this is going to be their last
word on the subject i mean
do you think it will be do you think it
should be
i think i think it will be and i think
it should be i think they've drawn a
line in sand they've had an opportunity
to
you know voice their side and now it's
time for them to move on
what advice would you give him in terms
of moving on and
and how he should be living his life now
um obviously i think with obviously
megan being six months pregnant you know
his priority now is
is his family um he talks at the end
about how he wants to
heal those relationships between his
brother and his father so
i'd like to see see that happen and i'd
like to see both families in both sides
of water and
getting on i mean how about how bad is
all those relationships do you think and
and is it possible
for them to be healed of course you know
any family there's always there always
tend to be arguments i do think you know
anything any sort of relationship can be
healed you know it's going to take time
it's going to take patience obviously
that he now has to
his priorities are megan archie and the
the up and coming baby um but hopefully
there'll be times an opportunity for him
to
to come back and sort of you know
rebuild those relationships
uh dean stott a friend of prince harry
uh great to talk to you today thanks a
lot for joining us and staying up
so late or getting up so early anyway in
los angeles
thank you